I am a Storyteller in every aspect of my
life from my career to what I've done
wrestling what films being a film
producer being an actor and through my
tattoos I tell the story of my life
if people ask me how many tattoos I have
I typically say like three because most
of them are just all connected together
I consider like one big tattoo my back I
did in big chunks throughout my
wrestling career but I had to because I
was wrestling so much that I couldn't
take the time needed to to let them heal
I did my back and I let it set for so
long without finishing that I had to go
back and retrace and do my whole back
over again so my tattoo on my back I've
got to have close to 50 hours on my back
just because I had to go over it so many
times from letting it sit so long and
not getting it finished if you notice
throughout my career whenever I got
injured and I was out for two three
months I would always come back with new
tattoos which the company actually loved
because the more new tattoos you have
the more new action figures you have so
you can kind of date my wrestling career
through my tattoos and through my the
tattoos all my action figures I talk a
lot about Guardians of the Galaxy really
not just changing my career but changing
my life because it really just gave me a
second shot because when I left
wrestling I literally lost everything
and I left it to go into acting but I
struggled for about three years because
I just couldn't get work I couldn't even
get an agent but I finally I landed that
part and it just after that I just my
phone started ringing and I never I've
been a working actor ever since I did
the first Guardians of the Galaxy the
makeup process also changed a lot
throughout the years for the first film
which was the hardest film the makeup
process typically took about five discus
hours to put on the application and
about two hours to take it off so I
spent most of my day on set but uh
actually in the makeup chair so I was
there before everybody got there and I
was there well after everybody left and
didn't get much sleep and when I looked
back on it I don't know how I made it
through that film and I was so you know
happy and grateful to be there that I
wasn't really looking at it as a
hardship it was just a huge opportunity
for me my first tattoo I immediately
break out and sweat when anybody asked
me that it's long gone I'm it's not my
proudest moment but when I was 18 years
old and Tattoos weren't as common then I
went to the local tattoo shop which
wasn't a very nice place and they
typically weren't at that time there was
this old biker named Rick who uh
I gave you my first tattoo and it was
this heart that looked like it was
cement and around it it said Heart of
Stone
and I saw it and I thought yeah that's
tough so he said well where do you want
it and I said well
uh I want it on my ass because I don't
want my dad to see it I don't want to
get in trouble and he did it he put
harder Stone on my ass and I immediately
regretted it and I lived with it for
years and got Razz so much through my
wrestling career take a shower with the
20 other wrestlers who are just
Relentless I finally got it covered up
it was just I have a cherry blossom tree
on my back and I said well just extend
it down and make the roots a cover-up so
that's what I did I have the roots of a
cherry blossom tree that covered up my
heart stone I have a lot of cover-ups I
think cover-ups are again a part of your
story part of your life story you know
you have regrets you make mistakes and
so you try to fix them as best you can
and that's what they are in my cover-ups
are repairs of mistakes this is a
cover-up that was actually a
girlfriend's name this is an ex-wife's
name and my mom always said don't don't
put a woman's name on you and I didn't
listen and so here they are cover-ups
but yeah let me learn oh so this one it
used to be a team logo I was a part of a
team of person I considered a friend and
someone I really looked up to and then
he uh later came out publicly so with
some anti-gay statements and you know
turned out to be you know an extreme
homophobe and so I had a huge issue with
it it's a personalized with me my mom's
a lesbian and I just can no longer call
him a friend and so I had it covered up
with with this oh my most painful so
that's a toss-up that's between uh my
feet which hurt they were torturous in
the back of my knee here the back of
this knee I actually started drinking in
the middle of this tattoo because my
tattoo artist was actually doing it at
my house and I said just give me a few
minutes I went and and took a shot came
back and it still kept hurting so I went
and took a couple more shots came back
he got back into it and I finally said
dude you gotta leave get out of my house
so I actually never finished this tattoo
the other one saw or my feet they just
weren't as big but they were just as
painful but I was able to get through
these in the city but they they hurt
they were torture so the tattoo that
took the longest to heal was actually
this one on my elbow and the reason it
took so long to heal is because my
tattoo artist put it on and I looked at
it in the mirror and I said that doesn't
look right so we put this stencil up
next to it and realize that he put it on
backwards he wasn't so nonchalant about
him saying not a big deal we'll fix it
so what he did was he Whited it out and
then he tattooed it on again so it's
like getting three tattoos in one day in
an area that's pretty sensitive so it's
swelled out like a balloon and it took
weeks for the swelling to go down but
that is by far it took the longest to
heal this tattoo here which is a Gracie
fighter symbol you know I have some are
very personal to me and you know some
are just things I liked when I was
growing up things I was a fan of I have
some you know Avengers and Guardians
which are personal to me but I expect
her was also very personal media film I
did James Bond film and I have a Wu-Tang
Clan Rizza from a routine Clan the
originator of the Wu-Tang Clan actually
helped me get my start in films Batman
just because I love him Rockstar because
yeah my favorite tattoo is uh this one
there's a portrait of my dogs my older
dogs I have three new dogs um we lost
him both to cancer she's still with my
ex-wife but she's older now but I am
going to get a save room for my newer
dogs I was always you really just taught
to be proud of my Heritage my mom's
Greek my dad's Filipino I didn't really
have close ties to my family but I just
saw even my mom was just always made me
very aware of who I was what my
background was to always be proud of
that and so I always kind of embrace
that being half Greek and half Filipino
always very proud of my roots and I
display it on my body a Filipino thing
Greek flag and I'll show another
Filipino flag and another Filipino son I
think I really embraced it when I was
older and when I got to visit the
Philippines and when I got to visit
Greece and just kind of kind of a
homecoming feeling especially when I
went to the Philippines for the first
time but I'm only half Filipino from the
United States but they embraced me like
I was 100 Filipino and I was born and
raised there you know that experience is
never going to make me feel anything
less in my life it's just it's just a
dream like it's just so surreal to go
there to a country and have them just
treat you like you know it's You're The
Prodigal Son
I have a few that didn't a few tattoos
that didn't turn out quite the way I
wanted so I have you know this one this
raven is not exactly one I wanted this
raven to look a lot more menacing but I
also have this tattoo here and I found
this really cool picture that I loved
and I really always always wanted to do
this gentlemen hooligan because I kind
of always felt like who I was I'm really
from the streets I grew up poor and that
was kind of life I knew until I was in
my 30s but I always consider myself a
gentleman as well I give a lot of
respect to people just because that's
just the person I am that's how I was
raised but I found this cool picture and
it was Killian Murphy from peaky
blinders and I asked John to alter it so
it didn't look so much like Killian
Murphy and I got it and I thought okay
that doesn't look exactly like I have a
tattoo of killing a Murphy on my thigh
but the first time I posted it on my
social media all I got was oh my God
you've got a tattoo of Kelly Murphy well
yeah I guess I do
it is what it is I'm a fan so you know
you know a little embarrassed but not
ashamed so Killian there you go your
face is tattooed on my thigh
I've Winnie the Pooh tattoo on the back
of my leg which I get asked about a lot
so I did a film uh called my spy with a
little actress named Chloe Coleman who
is one of my favorite people in the
world and so we went out on the Press
tour and at one uh Outlet we had to play
true or false to see how well we knew
each other they asked Chloe you said
true or false um Dave has a tattoo of
Winnie the Pooh and Chloe said well I
know you know most people might think
that Dave is is big and mean and scary
so he wouldn't have a Winnie the Pooh
tattoo but I know Dave he's like the
sweetest guy ever and he's just a big
teddy bear and I just love him to dance
she went on and on said all these great
things about me and she said so yes I
think it's true Dave has a Winnie the
Pooh tattoo and she was like got the
buzzer wrong and she was like oh she was
so disappointed and I was disappointed
for her and I said I don't have one but
because I love you so much I'm going to
get one so I got a one he is the Poo
tattoo for my little co-star Chloe
Coleman my latest tattoos were my two
neck tattoos so one is a Blade Runner
reference and the other is a Basquiat
Crown huge massive Phantom Bosque I was
by far my favorite artist they do have a
tattoo shop because it's always been a
dream of mine to own a tattoo shop just
because I love the culture I love the
environment I love sitting around tattoo
shops I love sitting around barber shops
I love the conversation that goes on the
camaraderie so the name of my tattoo
shop is DC Society Inc DC has a double
moniker for me it's uh I'm from
Washington DC but also stands for Dream
Chaser which I have used that hashtag
for years on my uh social media that's
kind of the way I look at my life I've
just chased my dreams no matter what
they were how crazy they seemed and uh
you know for some reason it seems to
work out for me